With a
brand recognition rate somewhere close to
99% in the States, it’s pretty safe to say
that almost everyone reading this has at least
heard of Juicy Fruit gum, if not also chewed
it at some point.
The question we’re looking at today is-
exactly what fruit is Juicy Fruit supposed
to taste like and does it actually contain
any dehydrated juice from that fruit?
Now you’d think that answering this question
would be as simple as picking up a pack of
Juicy Fruit gum and reading the ingredients
list, but as with most things in life, we
discovered it’s just not that easy.
For starters, the ingredients listed on a
pack of Juicy Fruit are incredibly vague;
the only real piece of useful information
you can glean from a pack itself is that the
gum contains “Natural and artificial flavors”.
Helpful…
This also isn’t helped by the fact that
Wrigley, the company who make Juicy Fruit,
are similarly coy about discussing what goes
into their product, often choosing to refrain
from mentioning any specific fruit in regards
to its flavour and excusing this evasive behaviour
by stating that the flavour is a trade secret.
That said, with a little digging, you’ll
find that, in the past, Wrigley has explicitly
said that Juicy Fruit contains notes of “lemon,
orange, pineapple and banana” in response
to emails from curious customers asking for
more specific information about Juicy Fruit’s
flavour.
Again though, this isn’t entirely helpful
in discerning whether or not the gum actually
contains fruit juice, since (always awesome)
science has made it possible to synthesize
almost any flavour we want.
JackfruitCuriously, there is a fruit out there
known to taste almost exactly like Juicy Fruit-
a lesser known fruit from the shores of Africa
and Asia known as Jackfruit.
Jackfruit tastes so much like Juicy Fruit
gum that it is often one of the first things
mentioned when it’s discussed by Western
media and there is a small, but nonetheless
dedicated subset of people who believe that
it is the key secret ingredient in the gum.
However, although Jackfruit tastes like Juicy
Fruit gum, this isn’t because Juicy Fruit
contains any juice from the Jackfruit (a dead
giveaway being that there are no records of
Wrigely importing the fruit or juice).
The real reason the two taste and smell so
similar is because they both (probably) contain
a chemical called, isoamyl acetate.
The reason we have to say “probably” is
because, as noted, Wrigley won’t confirm
what exactly goes into making Juicy Fruit,
which is their right as a company, but experts
are still pretty sure that isoamyl acetate
has something to do with Juicy Fruit.
One of the most compelling arguments for isoamyl
acetate being the primary flavouring agent
behind Juicy Fruit is that, like Jackfruit,
the chemical is said to smell very similar
to it.
Even in literature that doesn’t mention
Juicy Fruit by name, isoamyl acetate is said
to have an indistinct, almost indescribably
“fruity” smell that contains hints of
banana, peach and other similar sweet fruits,
which is pretty much the exact same way people
who haven’t eaten Jackfruit describe Juicy
Fruit.
Making this argument even more tantalising
is that, historically, one of the few ways
to obtain isoamyl acetate in commercially
viable quantities was as a by-product of whiskey
production.
When Wrigley first began producing Juicy Fruit
gum in 1893, they did so from a factory in
Illinois, the biggest whiskey State in America
at the time.
Suggesting that, perhaps, Wrigley sourced
isoamyl acetate, and hence Juicy Fruit’s
unique flavour, from the many factories producing
whiskey nearby.
juicy-fruitPerhaps the most damning piece
of evidence of all about Juicy Fruit’s flavour
being the result of artificially created chemicals
instead of real fruit is that they themselves
used to explicitly advertise the “artificial
flavor” of their product as a unique selling
point up until a few decades ago.
You see, early packs of Juicy Fruit starting
around the 1940s carried the slogan “The
Gum With the Fascinating Artificial Flavor”
which they used as a way of enticing customers
to try it.
It is only in recent years, with the trend
to avoid artificial chemicals in consumables,
that Wrigley has shied away from advertising
the fact that Juicy Fruit’s unique flavour
is, in all likelihood, the result of artificially
created chemicals rather than a cocktail of
chemicals directly extracted from fruit.